President Biden turning his back on
Israel to appease the far-left at the
most critical moment of the hostage
negotiations 11 more captives have been
released by Hamas and are now back in
Israeli territory temporary ceasefire
deal between Israel and the terror group
getting extended for two more days the
White House says samas is committed to
releasing another 20 women and children
over the next two days but so far only
one American has been released Jeff Paul
is live in Tel Aviv with more
Jeff yeah Jesse we just got word that
this latest group of hostages released
by Hamas they're on their way right now
to Israeli hospitals to get treatment
and get checked out and like the days
before these happened you know we saw
some delays today just like a few days
ago and that really just speaks to how
fragile these negotiations and this deal
is between Israel and Hamas now here's
what we know about this latest group
it's two mothers and nine children the
youngest kids being just 3 years old
we're also learning that all of those
kids left their dads behind inside Gaza
where they're still being held by Hamas
now the day before 14 Israelis made that
same Journey where they joined 26 other
Israelis released in previous days
they're all now in some sort of stage of
of treatment after spending roughly 7
weeks likely exclusively in the darkness
of Hamas tunnels however there are still
well more than 100 hostages being held
by Hamas now we could see more being
freed over the next two days as qari
officials broke the news a little
earlier today that they are extending
that temporary truce Israel had
previously said they would extend the
pause in fighting by one day for every
10 additional hostages released but keep
in mind once Hamas stops releasing those
hostages Israeli forces will likely
resume their combat operations in Gaza
to both eliminate Hamas and also get the
remaining hostages
out we want to receive another
additional 50 hostages uh Beyond tonight
on our way to bringing everyone home and
as soon as that framework expires Israel
will continue with full force towards
those three objectives eliminating Hamas
making sure the Gaza Strip can never be
a security threat to Israel and
releasing all the
hostages now as we saw in previous days
more Aid trucks made their way into Gaza
to help the civilians there and we're
also hearing that more uh Palestinian
prisoners a group of more than 30 will
be released just like in the previous
days Jesse Jeff thanks so
much and so far only one American
hostage has been released Kirby getting
pressed on that by Martha listen we're
very excited and the president was
personally involved in getting this
extension so 20 more hostages over the
next two days this process is working uh
so we're going to keep putting our
energies and efforts John was there any
promise you know when the president
spoke to the prime minister in Cutter
was there any promise that in this next
48 hour period we're going to see these
8 to9 Americans
I'm not going to get into diplomatic
conversations Martha I would just tell
you that we've made it plain and clear
that we want to see our American
hostages home with their families uh
we're glad that this thing got extended
for a couple of days and as the lives of
Americans hang in the balance Joe
Biden's going back on his promise to
fully support Israel the president
secretly apologizing to a group of
Muslim Americans for casting excessive
skepticism over the number of
Palestinian deaths released by theas run
Ministry of Health and instead of
playing straight with them and
explaining why you can't trust the
terrorists Biden telling them and I
quote I'm sorry I'm disappointed in
myself judge Janine what do you think
the president's calculation is in saying
that behind the scenes to the Muslim
Community well it's to me it appears
that he's he's moving left he knows the
numbers right now are not good for him
uh two months ago uh in an NBC poll he
was at 46% in September today he's at
31% among the those ages 18 to 34 so
he's dropped 15 points among that group
in the last two months but I think more
than that um he is trying to move left
to satisfy those people in the party the
progressives and I think that the
craziest part of it is this is the one
time he was telling the truth and now
he's going back on it saying you know
I'm sorry I really said that but I think
the biggest part of all of this besides
the politics and it's almost as though
you're seeing a movie I mean I feel like
I'm watching a movie now with the
Palestinians you know are sending our
hostages over and let any second
someone's going to get a call and say
turn around but the craziest part of
this is that now we have had I guess
it's 74 attacks against American
Military in seven weeks with well over
60 of our servicemen injured trapnel uh
traumatic brain injury they can be
lifelong injuries and you got John Kirby
saying today this afternoon n he says
we've sent them a strong message he has
not sent a strong message America has
basically said you in Iraq and Syria and
your proxies can hit our soldiers
whenever you want we're not going to
respond although I think we did we blew
up a garage or something and and now on
Thursday they apparently sent an
intercontinental ballistic missile and
we're not responding to this so the
first American soldier who dies as a
result of these proxies funded by Iran
the blood is going to be on the hands of
Joe Biden because he is not taking this
seriously enough and when people like
Joe Scarboro come out and say thank God
we've got Joe Biden otherwise we'd be in
a world war you know they're not they're
not understanding that in truth you know
unless we start blowing up bridges in uh
uh in Iran we're going to start getting
hit ourselves and so Dana just one
American hostage release so far I I mean
I I would be screaming bloody murder and
say like I'm not resting until the
Americans are home and you're not
resting until the Americans come home
like they no one involved in this should
have a good night's sleep until the
Americans are home and there's we have
ways to do that and power and I
understand all the little nuances and
everything and it's complicated Etc but
also then on the home front I just this
Washington Post story that had 27
sources a lot of them Anonymous about
this meeting that Joe Biden had at the
White House that included a lot of
Muslim leaders as well as staff and they
come to him and they say that they're
upset because he said on October 7th um
at at a press conference he said I have
no notion that the Palestinians are
telling the truth about how many people
are killed so they they want him to
retract that and he says to them I'm
sorry I'm disappointed in myself for
what I said excuse me first of all why
did you why would you think that Mr
President why would you think that the
gazen health Ministry would not be
telling the truth were they telling the
truth about the fact that their
headquarters are underneath the hospital
where the hostages were being held so he
has this meeting and instead of
explaining to them his decision-making
process he says I'm sorry and look we
don't know all about the meeting because
it was clearly leaked by the people that
were in there for the staffers that are
in there complaining guess what you
don't you don't have to work there and
you work at the pleasure of the
president and if I were them I would say
here's my position here's how I got to
it I hear you thank you your I respect
your opinion here's mine and then if
you're a staffer and you're so upset
about then you should leave these are
you had also the media protecting all
these staffers 200 Congressional
staffers and 400 Administration staffers
they don't release their names you think
that would happen in a trump
administration of course not the media
would be all over that and making sure
that they do it and it's just like these
people they're the ones who who said hey
we're okay with higher gas prices if you
get something for the climate movement
you know hey it's very it's okay to ban
even if it's unconstitutional no problem
oh guess what we'll do the same thing
for student loans there's like a t to
20% of the American public that is
pulling the president to the left and
he's at risk of losing everybody else
but at most he's at risk of losing the
principle that he has confidently been
keeping since October 7th and I think
that the Israelis are concerned about it
as much as they need him
Greg yeah uh I think he just does what
he's told it was interesting that he
never ever apologized about the uh
border patrol agents that he unfairly
maligned but that's because he wasn't
told to um but I mean I'll tell you how
I feel about the hostage release but my
feelings I have to preface mean nothing
compared to the families that I can
imagine the joy they feel seeing their
their family members come back and
that's a wonderful thing but having said
that for me I feel successfully
manipulated you know Hamas kidnapped
innocent people for this precise process
to unfold basically they robbed a human
bank to get human currency they hit the
casino they got the chips and now we're
playing by their rules so I feel Joy for
the families but I also feel like Kamas
has really they've really played this
thing well especially when you hear that
the captors treated the captives well
that's part of the process uh but to
treat the captives well first you had to
capture them and in the process of
capturing them you brutally and kill
brutally killed and raped hundreds of
innocent people so I think you can't let
these stories and you can't let this
process manipulate the core truth the
cause and effect behind this because I
think right now we're in the
rationalizing phase where now we're
rationalizing what's going on we're okay
we're going to get this and we forget
what began this not it's not the context
of History it's it started October 7th
you had the sky news reporter this is
was hilarious accused Israel of racism
for getting 50 hostages in exchange for
50 pales Ian prisoners because you know
Israel wouldn't want 150 hostages
because they don't believe that it's one
onone you idiot you idiot Hamas is
calling the shots here do you think
Israel would want more they would want
one to one but this has always been the
case that just shows you how effed up
the media is on this and it it it's
incredible anyway that's my feel yeah
everyone's now talking about Hamas
releasing hostages and three weeks ago
we were talking about Hamas slaughtering
men women and children I don't so good
to be back around the table hope
everyone had a great holiday I don't
think that anyone uh suggesting and
first let me let me I agree with you any
staffer in the White House who disagrees
with policy in the white house has every
right to they should quit or or they can
just do their job and accept that the
president is the president of United
States and yes sir Mr President or they
should quit if they disagree with the
president they have every right to but I
wouldn't have met with anybody if I was
a president United States with staffers
who disagree with me I'd say show the
papers at the door number two I give the
president a lot of credit but although
they said what they want to say about
him and what they're thinking about him
and leaked something from the meeting I
I can only tell you what the president's
publicly doing one we have two of the
most highly sophisticated and highly
equipped military Assets in that region
today number two the Israelis and it's
giving Israelis the protection to do
what they're doing Greg I agree with you
October 7 we can never we cannot lose
that as a sight of what we're doing and
why we're doing but we we have to
understand that if you're a national
security adviser you're on that team in
the white house or the state department
you have to think about some of these
things as you think about what happens
when we win because we will win for
those who are active in our country and
those who are advocating on behalf of
Palestinians you have every right to in
fact I join you in wanting a two-state
solution but if you believe so strongly
in that position you should understand
that if Hamas would release all the
soldiers there would the killing in in
Gaza and the West Bank would stop
because so many would ask Israel to
let's now reframe and reset and regroup
how we go about trying to find a
solution if you're blaming Israel or the
United States for Palestinian deaths
after what's happened over the last few
days the the the the ceasefire came
about because Israel de Hamas decided to
release soldiers from the outset
president Netanyahu I don't agree with
all the time and still have my issues
with but I agree with him here he said
we have to recover hostages and degrade
Hamas we are degrading Hamas and we're
getting hostages released if we want the
killing to stop in the West Bank if we
want the killing to stop in Gaza release
of the hostages and then we can have a
reasonable serious conversation but I
would say to the president where Dana
started I wouldn't be I wouldn't waste
my time entertaining the ideas and
thoughts of some of my staff who W who
are against my ideas and against our
proposal and against against our
positions let them quit they have every
right to we live in a free country but
you shouldn't be wasting your time if
that's the position of the country keep
doing what you're doing we're gaining
progress we making progress you're
saying that would not happen in a Ford
Administration the last thing that would
Happ okay see Harold's got to run coming
up Harold not
Gerald hi everyone I'm Brian killme I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now